c'est l'étude mon travail anting ici aux
trois ilets qui se chargera des archives
de france antilles un véritable trésor
des milliers d'articles de photos des
témoignages jusqu'au dernier numéro de
samedi dernier véritable actif du
quotidien qui pourrait être vendu mais
combien est acquis en attendant certains
particuliers ouvrent leurs collections
s'était présenté comme cela christian
est de ducos il est amoureux de son pays
du cyclisme et de son journal pour lui
recourir aux archives est très important
j'ai eu l'occasion d'y aller
personnellement moi qui ai eu des
éléments surtout les tous passés cet
adieu de 65 que je connais que j'ai vécu
1965 et j'ai récupéré les photos qui
sont sur un ordinateur
car comme christian rocher tout le monde
peut se rendre par exemple à la
bibliothèque schoelcher dont une des
missions est de garder des copies de
toutes les publications locales y
compris france antilles a une
particularité c'est que nous avons le
france antilles en triple exemplaire
puisque nous gardons donc une partie de
la collection pour les générations
futures donc c'est de la conservation et
nous avons également deux jeux donc un
jeu qui est consultable par le public
mais à force de manipulations il finit
par s'abîmer il est complété par le
troisième jeu qui est un dépôt légal feu
aux archives territoriales et qui nous
permet donc de compléter nos lacunes
dans les collections le journal paru en
kiosque est sûr de pouvoir être
consultés mais à dire vrai le véritable
enjeu est certainement ailleurs france
antilles a été et est aujourd'hui de
poser tes addona mémoire martiniquaise
en plus
en termes d'économie graphique il ya
aucun organisme il ya aucune association
il n'y a aucune y a personne qui a
autant de photos mais ce sont des
milliers et des milliers de photos qui
sont là dans des casiers là aujourd'hui
c'est cette mémoire là qui qui qui doit
être sauvée à ce jour les archives de
france antilles représenterait 12
téraoctets de mémoire électronique